a small army of police officers follow
presidential candidate gustavo petro
wherever he goes
on stage men with large bulletproof
shields stand on either side of him a
reminder of what it means to run for
office in colombia especially when
promising a drastic rebuke of the status
quo
we are on the cusp of changing history
in colombia changing our history so full
of violence of injustice of social
exclusion to the possibility of building
a country at peace
as colombians head to the polls the
climate is less than peaceful petra's
rise from clandestine rebel to the
threshold of becoming the country's
first leftist president has meant an
uptick in death threats which he blames
on the country's elites
a progressive force has never governed
colombia i call what we had here a
hereditary democracy which is not
democracy 40 families have kept the
control of the country for 200 years
they have concentrated the political and
economic power excluding the majority
the candidate's promise of radical
change has pushed him to the top of the
polls with 40 percent of the vote but
probably not enough to avoid the runoff
in june
petra is moderated a stone during the
campaign going as far as making a very
public and legally binding pledge not to
expropriate any private assets among
other actions but those haven't been
enough to overcome many people's fear
his main rival federico gutierrez backed
by most of colombia's traditional
parties is running on a pro-business
platform he says he understands
colombian's social demands but cautions
against embracing policies that would
put the country's stability at risk
look at venezuela look at nicaragua it's
a social and economic model very
different from the one we propose we
will offer change to colombia but change
that will not put the country at risk we
don't need any more hate speech and
class warfare
some political analysts say the growing
calls for reforms come from the signing
of a peace deal with farc rebels five
years ago and the elimination of at
least that main source of war
has led to
rising social demands and rising social
protests that has been undetended
and that is now giving way to
uh you know popular opinion favoring a
leftist candidate who is speaking
directly to many of the social concerns
being expressed by very many different
sectors of colombian society
but as this rattled country looks left
for the first time
many wonder if indeed a majority is
ready for such a historic leap
alessandro rampietti al jazeera bogota